prime day has come and gone and there's
more of July behind us than in front of
us it's time to take a look at the new
offerings you should keep your eyes open
for on Amazon Prime video in August 2009
teen Amazon Prime's new original series
carnival row mixes fantasy mystery and a
politically tense environment that for
some people at least feels all too
familiar at this point
starring Orlando Bloom is human Rycroft
Philo Straits and cara delevingne as the
winged fairy vignette ston loss carnival
Row is set in a Victoria era city for
the kinds of fantasy creatures were not
used to seeing outside of the Lord of
the Rings or a Dungeons & Dragons
campaign are in everyday fact of life
kind of like that bright movie but maybe
you know better
fairy lives don't matter today but while
these creatures existences are accepted
that doesn't mean the humans of this
fictional world liked them very much the
fantasy creatures of carnival row like
vignettes are refugees from a war-torn
land and are subjected to inhuman laws
while living in the city one freedom
denied them as romance with humans
making the affair between Rycroft and
vignettes a risky one while the pair
wrestle with that looming danger
they must also investigate a string of
unsolved murders all eight hour-long
episodes of carnival row will be
released on Amazon Prime on August 30th
for the premise so unique and promising
it definitely looks to be worth checking
out if the trailer for next year's top
gun maverick got your blood pumping but
you don't want to wait until 2020 to see
Tom Cruise in action
Amazon Prime might have a partial
solution for you on August 23rd 2018 s
critically lauded Mission Impossible
Fallout lands on the service featuring
starring turns from cruise Henry Cavill
and ving rhames cavils career owes a lot
to Zack Snyder who directed the actors
comic book icon Superman and Man of
Steel Batman vs Superman Tom Justice and
Justice League and Amazon Prime might be
a favorite place for Zack Snyder fans in
August
Snyder's Persian war epic 300 will be
Prime's very first new August arrival
with his original story sucker punch
arriving later in the month while a lot
of Snyder's superhero flicks will arrive
on crime in August
Pierre mal del Toro's Hellboy 2 the
Golden Army will be there and it will be
joined by other monster filled action
flicks like 2014's Godzilla and the
Aaron Eckhart led graphic novel
adaptation I Frankenstein the process of
buying a home isn't known for its lack
of stress but if you find yourself
looking for a new place to hang your
hats and find the whole thing impossibly
frustrating maybe drop by Amazon Prime
at the end of August for 1986's horror
sequel poltergeist to the other side
starring Craig T Nelson Jobeth Williams
and Heather or Rorick poltergeist 2 is
the second entry into the saga of the
free lean family people who just can't
get a break when it comes to where they
plant their stakes though they've moved
from the home where vengeful spirits
plagued them in 1982 s poltergeist the
family soon learns the truth of the old
adage no matter where you go there the
creepy ghosts from the first movie are
but if supernatural fears aren't your
cup of tea Amazon is also offering some
scares based war firmly in the real
world with 2013's manuscripts don't burn
made by Iranian filmmaker Muhammad Rasul
off the thriller follows a writer named
Kaz Roth as he attempts to escape I ran
with his politically charged writing
after the country's authorities learn of
his plans
in 1996 former US Director of Central
Intelligence William Colby disappeared
under mysterious circumstances 15 years
later a documentary was released called
the man nobody knew in search of my
father CIA spy master William Colby
directed and narrated by the late Colby
son Karl driven by a son's need to know
the truth about his father and
inevitably tied to some of the most
important historical events of the 20th
century the man nobody knew succeeds as
what philadelphia inquirer Stephen Rea
calls quote a deeply personal film and
an important historical document the
documentary arrives on Amazon Prime on
August 31st if you prefer something with
a bit more distance from the present-day
1983 s Western drama sacred ground
premieres the same day the film is
noteworthy both as a rare Western
produced in the 1980s well after the
popularity of the genre had faded it's
also the final film of character actor
Tim MacIntyre are recognizable oh it's
that guy of the 60s and 70s it's at the
same year the American Civil War began
sacred ground revolves around the
ostracism that awhi
man and Native American woman face when
they choose to live as man and wife
if you need some more laughter in your
life Amazon Prime is serving up some
uniquely humorous offerings in August
the indie comedy computer chess shows up
on prime at the end of the month and if
you haven't seen it it's well worth a
look
2013's critics couldn't get enough of it
filmed completely on analog video and as
the AV club's Mike D'Angelo put it
having the look of an industrial
training film from the 80s computer
chess unfolds over a weekend summits of
computer chess programmers the kind of
smart tech people who helped create the
world we live in now if you find
yourself enjoying that style of quirky
nerdy humor keep things going by
following an atomic scientist to a town
full of people eating salesmen in 1999's
comedy horror top of the food chain but
if you don't want to spend a weekend
simply nerding out you can instead spend
some time with Anna Kendrick and Blake
Lively in the twisted black comedy
mystery movie a simple favor what are
you saying about me being a psycho or
for something a little sweeter and more
family-friendly watches Michael Keaton
dies and comes back to life as a snowman
in 1998's Jack Frost hey Charlie thanks
for giving me a second chance to be your
dad
staying in with that high concept movie
you won't just give you a weird blast of
nostalgia it can also help take your
mind off of just how hot it is outside
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you